roy blunt
richard burr
shelley moore capito bill cassidy susan
collins joni ernst lindsey graham mitch
mcconnell lisa murkowski
rob portman mitt romney tom tillis todd
young
and most of all john cornyn those are
the republican senators who just voted
to advance the democrats latest gun
control bill
the worst part of this vote is not
that these senators squished on an issue
that is important to conservatives
these senators often squish on issues
that are important to conservatives we
have come to expect it sometimes it's
almost politically understandable for
some of these people at least in the
blue and purple states
the worst part of this vote
is that they squished at a time when
they had absolutely no reason to
the political winds are entirely at the
republicans backs
even democrat strategists are expecting
a red tsunami in the midterm elections
democrats are down historically on those
midterm polls the gop has momentum on
virtually every issue american voters
generally are extremely supportive of
gun rights and polls show that even the
voters who do not like guns don't really
care about them relative to other issues
the worst part of this is that it is
completely needless a completely
needless surrender by republicans who
have absolutely no idea what time it is
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from vs who says
weird demon mickey is my favorite
impersonation that michael has done so
far ha ha
i'm so glad to hear it haha don't listen
to your parents kids
just go spend all your time with drag
queens
that's what they do this is what they do
the the democrats take something that we
love that we're accustomed to that's
familiar and then they kill it they kill
it dead they beat it to a bloody pulp
and then they crawl inside of its body
and they reanimate it
like a weird spooky creepy ghost zombie
demon and then they use that thing that
we have affection for to push their
radical agenda that's what they've done
to i guess every american institution
and that's what they're doing to mickey
now as well it's not good we got to
protect ourselves when you want to
protect your home you got to check out
ring right now go to ring.com
knowles it's the summer people are going
to be traveling a lot you see i'm in a
hotel room right now i'm traveling when
you're traveling whether you're
traveling alone whether you're traveling
with your family you want to keep your
house safe
okay you want to keep your family safe
yourself safe all that stuff so that's
why you need a ring you know about rings
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to people wherever you are in the
house outside the house on the other
side of the world you know about ring
alarm rings award-winning alarm system
now you got to go pro
okay now is the time it is it's the time
to go
pro be a pro just like me ring alarm
protects your doors your windows your
whole physical home ring alarm pro
protects your digital home as well
think of how much of your life you live
on the internet would you protect your
physical documents would you protect all
your financial documents would you maybe
shred them put them in a safe place well
if you would do that why wouldn't you
protect your digital life where you've
got so much more information protect the
whole thing ring is the way to do it
cnet calls it a giant leap for home
security gopro be a pro like me head on
over to ring dot com slash knowles k w l
e s that is ring.com
knowles
i understand it's very easy to sit
behind a microphone it's harder to build
political consensus in washington dc and
get something done i do i get it it's
why i don't take
pot shots at politicians broadly i
understand there needs to be compromise
sometimes you need to work the levers of
power i get it my issue with this stupid
gun bill that these 14 squish
republicans are backing my issue is it
comes down to one word why
why why are you backing this
well well because we have to do
something
do we you're not doing anything about
inflation you're not doing anything
about immigration
you're not doing all that much about
giving us back our way of life after
covid it was pretty much just a federal
judge that let us do that
you're not doing a ton on
on pro-life i will give mitch mcconnell
credit for the judges and then the
judges might overrule roe v wade so okay
that's that's something the senators
aren't doing a whole lot for that
well you're not doing you're not doing
much on a whole range of it you're not
doing much about the debt you're not
doing much about about anything
but this this is the one issue taking
away american second amendment rights
that's the issue where we have to do
something why well because
of the the polls what about the polls
you're doing great in the polls and a
lot of americans love guns
and
the americans that don't love guns don't
care it doesn't rank very high even for
the most anti-gun americans the furthest
left democrats
gun rights the second amendment is not
at the top of their priority list you
don't have to do any of this we don't
know exactly what is in this bill
but it's nothing good really
at least the the really consequential
parts of this democrat gun bill
you've got red flag laws which in
principle sound fine right but the
devil's in the details because they can
be so broad that the red flag just
becomes you
did you vote for trump red flag
do you
do you like buying guns red flag
do you have you read the constitution
boy that's a red flag we're gonna have
to take away your constitutional rights
so incredibly broad and and what's the
purpose of it i would even understand
if the democrats were pushing this law
as a sincere way to stop these specific
horrific shootings that just took place
in texas and in buffalo they're not
doing that the republicans have proposed
what should be uncontroversial
very modest reforms that would have
protected the school in texas would have
protected other schools too lock the
doors get some armed guards
to be stationed at the schools maybe
allow teachers who have the right to
keep and bear arms to to carry their
weapons really basic stuff and the
democrats won't go with any of that
because their object is not to protect
the schools their object is just to push
the same stupid gun laws they wanted for
50 years
so the democrats are not sincere on this
at all why do republicans have to go
along with this why
why i don't i hate to vent to you today
you know i don't like complaining but i
why
do republicans have to clutch defeat
from the jaws of victory do you think
that this is going to win over democrat
votes in the midterms it's not
do you think this is going to win over
the centrists the centrists don't really
care and the moderates and the
independents they're voting on gas
prices they're voting on the economy
they're voting on jobs they're voting on
really basic stuff they're not voting on
the second amendment do you think this
is going to help motivate republicans to
come out to the polls it's not it's
going to depress the republican vote
why is someone going to go vote for john
cornyn well they're not going to vote
for john cornyn and he's not up for
election he's probably not going to run
for reelection which is why a lot of
these squishes are getting behind this
thing is they know that they're not
going to have to face the voters again
so they can sell them out which is what
so frequently happens it's amazing it's
it's not even just that well republicans
are doing really well on the economic
issues and the economic issues are going
to bring us to victory in november so
we've got to downplay the cultural
issues we're winning on the cultural
issues too the the issues that are
actually pushing conservatives across
the finish line are extremely cultural
issues
it's transgenderism in movies and
schools it's critical race theory it's
it's pro-life for that matter great news
just came out of south dakota south
dakota just closed its last
abortion center
it's the last one boom there aren't any
more in south dakota governor christie
gnome tweeted about this she said
abortions have stopped in south dakota
we have prayed for this day and now it
is here now we must redouble our focus
on taking care of mothers in crisis help
is available for you adoption is an
option you are never alone this is
fabulous stuff
christy gnome has
been a little bit squishy at times at
least on that transgender issue and so
conservatives are skeptical of her but
this is great news got to give credit
where credit's due
and and by the way the very fact that
christinome is the one pushing this is
great news for conservatives precisely
because she has squished on certain
cultural issues precisely because she
initially caved to pressure on
transgender sports before she then
reversed her position
she's not above playing politics and
figuring out which way the wind is
blowing and she knows that on these
cultural issues in this year the year of
our lord 2022 with the midterm elections
right around the corner all of the wind
is in the sales of the republicans on
cultural matters what do the democrats
have to say in response to this
what's the democrats best offering here
this this article from the washington
post
i thought it was a spoof at first i
thought it was satire
the article
says this texas teen wanted an abortion
now she has twins
brooke alexander found out she was
pregnant 48 hours before the texas
abortion ban took place
the article online on social media it
shows this girl
taking care of the two twin babies
she's
it actually shows the babies even as it
insinuates that we should be able to
kill those babies
it shows the two little babies and mommy
taking care of the two little babies i
had to wonder
is there some secretly pro-life editor
at the washington post how did this
possibly get through either the editors
are so
completely oblivious
so cold
such
stone cold psycho patrick bateman
chopping people up in their freezers
that they think that that presenting a
picture of a mommy taking care of her
twin babies is going to convince people
yeah we should kill them we should be
allowed to kill those babies or
someone at wapo is secretly pro-life i
actually think i have to believe
it's the latter in the article
you see that they say
sometimes brooke imagined her life if
she hadn't gotten pregnant and if texas
hadn't banned abortion just days after
she decided that she wanted one she
would have been at school rushing from
class to her shift at texas roadhouse
eyes on a real estate license
that would finally get her out of corpus
christi she pictured an apartment in
austin and enough money for a trip to
hawaii where she would swim with the
dolphins in water so clear she could see
her toes when both babies finally
started eating brooke took out her phone
and restarted the timer that had been
running almost continuously since the
day
they were born it would be two and a
half hours until they had to eat again
are they serious do they are they
i i have to think they're being ironic
here
or that someone involved in this article
is being ironic yeah
brooke she she could have gone and kept
working at texas roadhouse and then she
could have gone and uh
gotten an apartment in austin
you couldn't pay me to get an apartment
in austin austin is a gross place full
of derelict people who were doing all
sorts of crazy things and homeless
people and crime and all sorts of libs
running around wreaking havoc
or she could feed her beautiful little
babies and then and by the way by the
way at the end of this article
at the end of this article the final bit
is she told herself that alternate life
didn't matter anymore she had two babies
she loved more than anything else in the
world i do she said tears in her eyes
brooke pulled out her phone once they
finished the ceremony one hour 15
minutes time to grab some lunch and head
home the babies would be hungry
even the washington post is wittingly or
unwittingly
sympathizing with the conservatives with
the republicans with pro-life on a
contentious issue on the cultural
matters all of that to say now is not
the time
to squish
speaking of life
where there is life someday there will
be death that's why you've got to take
seriously your future and go check out
epic will this is something that people
put off and put off and put off do not
put it off
do it right now it's going to take you
five minutes 10 minutes you're going to
be with the best guys ever who are
protecting so many of us over at the
daily wire epic will if you god forbid
or to drop right now
what would happen to your kids
what would happen to your stuff what
would happen to your life who would make
the decisions for your kids and for your
stuff and for your property and for your
family would it be people you trust
would it be in accordance with your
wishes as you lay it out in your will or
would it be
the state or would it be institutions
that hate your guts and do things to
your kids and your stuff and your family
that you don't want to have done just go
do the responsible thing it takes no
time
it can start at just 119
takes five minutes to set up go to
epicwheel.com by the way you'll get 10
off right now if you use promo code
knowles that's know w l e s go to
epicwill.com
use the guys that are protecting so many
daily wire families do it five minutes
you're done it doesn't cost very much
money you get a ten percent discount
code promo code nola's epicwill.com
speaking of young girls
two california teachers
just caught an earful from an angry
parent really a room of angry parents
because these two california teachers
allegedly we have to say allegedly
groomed
coached a 12 year old girl
into becoming transgender
behind
her parents back
these teachers come in and act as if
they have nothing wrong they've done
nothing wrong a mistake
how long of a mistake how many mistakes
are we going to take before my child
almost lost her life they didn't tell me
that my child was suicidal
you allowed these teachers to open their
classrooms teaching predatorial
information to a young child a mindful
child that doesn't even know how to
comprehend it all
how do you not know what was going on on
your own campuses
did you think that no parent would ever
come forward you will not quiet me today
i will stand here today and protect my
child along with every other child who
has not come forward yet
do you do do they have psychiatry
degrees that i was unaware of because i
didn't hire them okay i did not hire
them to sit there and nitpick my child's
brain
you took away my ability to parent my
child
even before i had any knowledge
i didn't even get to show support you
asked for support i didn't get a chance
you planted seeds miss caldera and miss
baracki mr brook and you miss tagarin
your job was to educate my child in math
science english etc do your job and let
me do mine
[Applause]
the key here to this video it's
heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking could you imagine
could you imagine if it were you i was
putting myself in this woman's shoes i
guess it's sort of unclear even if the
child is a daughter or a son because
well because transgenderism confuses all
of those sorts of things and she keeps
saying my child my child my child
could you imagine if it were your child
i don't know that i could refrain from
violence against the teachers if i found
out that some teacher were secretly
grooming my my sweet little baby boy
behind my back and confusing him and
giving him pathologies that are going to
last the rest of his life
and trying to convince him that he's a
little girl and convince him to go on
hormones and change his pronouns change
his government documents chop up his
body someone were trying to
harm my child
was actually harming my child like that
i'm not sure i could refrain from
violence
i like to think i could i don't think it
would be good
to commit
some act of vigilante violence but that
is the way that it would pull
on a on a father's or mother's heart
this woman is being positively
restrained even as she's screaming her
head off and steam is coming out of her
ears
and you know the most amazing part of
this video it's not even
it's obviously not that the mother's
getting angry it's not even that the
teachers these creeps these psychos
are grooming the little kid and screwing
up the kid's life and having
sexual perverse conversations with a
little kid
behind the parents backs the most
amazing part of the video
is the unanimous applause
from everyone in the room
everyone knows what's up
everyone knows that this is wrong
everyone knows what time it is
on these allegedly controversial
cultural issues all the people get it
the only people that don't get it
are
in the crooked ruling class
are the the teacher unions and the
people who are controlling the
institutions notably the academic
educational institutions but corporate
america too and government america and
big tech and the media those guys
they don't get it
everyone else does get it
we're not the crazy ones okay they're
they're telling us that we're the crazy
ones and we're we're abusing our kids
and what you'd rather have a dead
daughter than a living son
and and you're you're you're you just
don't understand you're just a knuckle
dragging troglodyte because you think
that a man isn't isn't actually a woman
how dare you you big dumb idiot you
don't even have a degree in gender
studies like i do yeah you didn't even
get a master's degree in some fake thing
so you you don't have a righteous
opinion everyone gets it
other than these people it's a it's a
it's a message for it's a message for
the squishes it's a message for the
centrists now it's not the time to
squish if you
if you are reading and consuming the
establishment media and listening to all
the establishment self-appointed
geniuses who are running our country you
might be convinced this is a tough call
well it's a complex issue it's not
complex at all the people in that room
didn't think it was complex know what
the voters of virginia didn't think it
was complex the voters in florida don't
think it's complex the the moviegoers
who could have gone to see the buzz
lightyear movie didn't think it was
complex no one thinks it's complex
except for the
the pudding brains the absolute
mushy-headed perverts who are running
our major institutions
you do not need to squish we are winning
on so many fronts right now
speaking of the schools major major
supreme court win in
for conservatives for christians for
religious liberty a case called carson v
macon carson v making me really happy
that we have six quasi-conservatives on
the supreme court i'll tell you that the
way that the case works it's about a
maine law
that allows public money to be spent on
private schools
because maine
is in many parts a sparsely populated
state and so
every school-aged child has the right to
a free public education in some places
in the rural districts they don't have
public high schools and so there's a
work around where they can take the
public money and go to some private
school with public assistance
there was a law passed in maine that
said that you can't take that money to
any christian school
so you can take it to whatever kind of
wacky private school you want to it just
can't be christian the supreme court six
three struck it down
which means even roberts who frequently
sides with the libs he's the swing vote
he's the squish vote even he sided with
the conservatives here
the left is losing their mind they're
saying that this is a major attack on
the
firm wall of separation between church
and state sonia sotomayor on the court
says
this court continues to dismantle the
wall of separation between church and
state that the framers fought to build
in just a few years the court has
upended constitutional doctrine shifting
from a rule that permits states to
decline to fund religious organizations
to one that requires states in many
circumstances to subsidize religious
indoctrination with taxpayer dollars
constitutional doctrine do you
could you would you mind if you're not
driving or something would you mind
maybe pulling up the text of the
constitution on your phone or on your
computer and just do a quick little word
search
search for um
wall of separation between church and
state
separation between you're not it's going
to come up blank
because that's not a constitutional
doctrine i feel like i wanna i'm in that
meme of the of the psychiatrist talking
to the lunatic young man in the padded
cell walls you say this excuse me young
man sir this wall of separation between
church and state is it is it in the room
with us right now do you
do you hear it do you feel the wall
because it's not real it's not real it
was never real
that phrase the wall of separation
between church and state it comes from a
private letter from thomas jefferson it
means absolutely nothing in the american
law
what it might sort of kind of maybe
refer to is the establishment clause and
the free exercise clause in the first
amendment which says that the federal
government will not establish a church
at the national level the reason that
the federal government did not establish
a church at the national level is not
because we were going to be an atheist
secular country and have nothing to do
with religion the reason we didn't
separate established a church at the
national level is because there were
already established churches at the
state level
and they persisted for decades after
ratification unfortunately
the the 14th amendment one of the
negative possibly unintended
consequences of the 14th amendment
is that later on the supreme court
interpreted that
to mean that
you would deprive states of the rights
to do a whole lot of things and you
would apply
these
the federal constitution and the rights
enumerated therein
to the states to override the states
it's a
topic i suppose for another day you
could go on at great length about that
but it's not in the constitution at the
very least we have to say the separation
of church and state is not in the
constitution and it can't possibly be
because just zooming out from the legal
constitutional perspective for a second
getting into the just broad
philosophical historical perspective
all states have to have something to do
with religion because all law has to
have something to do with religion
because all civil laws and
constitutional laws ultimately have to
say something about and derive from the
natural and moral law so it's just it's
just simply a fact when we come together
in political society we have to hold
certain things sacred and certain things
taboo we have to value certain things
when we have to
discard other things
we we have to encourage certain things
and discourage other things the basic
charge of statecraft is do good and
avoid evil and have human flourishing
and pursue happiness
and and give give people the kind of
society that we want to live in
especially when you're talking about
self-government
now all you had with this main law that
was just struck down was a religious
discrimination against christianity
you could support the the religion of
transgender gnosticism
you could support the religion
of secular humanism human rights you
could support the religion of lgbt
elementop
you could support all those the religion
of marxism you could support all those
things the only religion you couldn't
support is christianity
the only the only religion you're not
allowed to support is true religion
traditional religion the religion that
animated our country and our
civilization that didn't make a lot of
sense and so it's very good that the
court struck it down you know really
exciting news from the supreme court
really exciting news here in nashville
because do you know what's coming up
next week daily wire's biggest event of
the year back stage live at the historic
ryman auditorium if you have not gotten
your tickets yet i think there might
still be a few left go check it out if
not you can stream it at dailywire.com
knowles this is the biggest baddest
coolest toughest event of the year if
you missed it last year check it out
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
backstage live happens right here in
nashville on june 29th get your tickets
now
it's going to be incredibly fun i think
there's a few tickets left you can head
on over to dailywire.com
ryman
if there are no tickets left if you
cannot make it to nashville you can
stream it
go to dailywire.com
knowles you will get 25 off that's
dailywire.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s you will get the entire
daily wire content library you will get
the duck devouchy docu-series you will
get our movie on the history of roe v
wade that legacy of death you will get
what is a woman you will get terror on
the prairie you will get everything
dailywire.com 25 off we'll be right back
with a lot more
welcome back to the show
here is the rub with the big
conservative win at the supreme court
the supreme court says in carson v macon
and be making michael very happy
six three
uh you can't discriminate against
christian schools if you're gonna fund
private schools with taxpayer dollars
you've got to fund the christian ones
too so here's what's gonna happen
the satanic temple
which is a group of
left-wing atheists
they are going to start
filing a lot of cases a lot of lawsuits
they're going to maybe establish some
facade of a school and they're going to
try to get taxpayer dollars to teach
satanism
the satanic temple is
different than the church of satan
sort of the church of satan they are
very committed satanists who worship the
devil the satanic temple is a group of
internet atheists who just worship the
satan ironically it's just ironic it's
just really funny aren't they so clever
and they hate christianity they hate
christianity they want they want a
firmer separation of church and state
you'll notice though they always try to
make this distinction between the church
of satan and satanic temple they say
we're totally different things
you see they worship satan earnestly and
we worship satan ironically and my
answer to that is always
are you sure
are you sure
you can worship satan ironically
i'm not sure you can
your antipathies are both the same you
both hate
god and you both hate christianity
you your symbolism is the same you are
both
exalting symbols of
satan
your practical effect in society is the
same you're both seeking to undermine
good virtuous
institutions and religion and cultural
practice and church and replace it with
hedonism and pursuing one's own will i
mean i think of aleister crowley i think
of the more prominent satanists in
history they've said the only thing the
only moral law that you should follow is
do as thou wilt
just do whatever you want to do that's
the only moral law that's the true
golden rule they say and then you look
at the ironic hipster or lefty atheist
church of satan they say the exact same
thing
yeah just do whatever you want if it
feels good do it
i i feel for them the the ironic
edgelord atheist
satan temple because someday they're
going to be in for a really big surprise
someday when they're you know when it's
all over and they're
facing the judgment seat they're going
to find out you can't ironically worship
satan
more broadly
you can't do something ironically all
the time
and have it still be ironic
eventually if you if you live your life
hipsters really were very guilty of this
they would just do that you know they
were apathetic to everything they would
just do things ironically haha isn't
that funny but if you if you do things
ironically all the time it just becomes
sincere it's just earnest it's just
that's just what you do that is how you
live and then it's over and that was
your life and then you're you're uh
being tortured by the devil for eternity
that's not good don't do that
you don't want to do that so
there's there's two
there's two reactions
to
the satanists inevitably trying to get
public funds in maine to fund their
satanic schools the first is
would it really be all that different
from the public schools
if
if actual outright self-styled satanists
formed a school
would the curriculum look all that
different from what is currently being
taught in schools namely
gosh drag queen story hour drag queens
often dressed up like actual demons
going around and working for little kids
the teachers like the ones in california
grooming a poor little child and
convincing the child that the child
should should disregard his parents and
should be pretend to be the other sex
and go on cross-sex hormones and
frankly i think the satanists might
blush i think that the in some cases the
left-wing school teachers that are
already around and the left-wing
administrators
would out out satanist the satanists
you'd have these satanists in maine they
say yo cool it buddy i don't want to
chop up little kids all right
come on can't we don't we have any
limits anymore so that's the first
that's the first part the second part
though which is which is a legitimate
constitutional and legal question is
can we have limits
can we say
yes we're going to fund
non-non-sectarian not secular private
schools with taxpayer money
and christian schools with taxpayer
money and jewish schools with taxpayer
money and muslim schools with taxpayer
money but not
satanist schools
can we do that
i think we can
i think we can we have to undo
some some stupid concepts that have
cropped up in our jurisprudence in the
last few decades
for one the idea that we the government
has to be completely neutral
on on all questions of politics culture
and religion that's a that's a new idea
the idea of viewpoint neutrality which
some of the squish conservatives defend
that idea dates back to 1995.
this is not something that george
washington and and thomas jefferson and
john adams were defending okay these
guys if you told
if you went back to my rule of thumb the
old wwd
rule what would washington do wwffd
rule what would the founding fathers do
and you said hey this government that
you're setting up
the brilliant ideas enshrined in the
constitution and in this country uh it
it naturally will follow from those
ideas that we need taxpayer-funded
satanic temples
they would
laugh at you or they would they would
look at you with bemusement or they
would chase you out of town on a rail so
we know that that wasn't the idea from
the beginning if you had told someone
this in 1947
that this is how things would be used
they would laugh at you they would look
at you with bemusement frankly even if
you told someone this in the 60s other
than the radicals of the new left people
would they would laugh at you and yet
here we are so what went wrong
number of things went wrong
the overt government discrimination
against christianity that went wrong
kicking prayer out of public schools
pretending that the constitution
prohibits prayer in public schools it
doesn't
kicking the bible out of public schools
pretending that the constitution bans
the bible the most important book ever
written even if you don't believe in it
you have to at least admit it's the most
important book ever written without
which western civilization is completely
is completely incomprehensible
that's now that's the only book you
can't teach in schools you think that's
in the constitution i don't think so
you've got to go back and and and
ultimately what you have to undo is what
sotomayor was talking about this
fictional notion that there is a firm
wall of separation between church and
state there's not it has never existed
it's never been a real thing
at least for the first part of our
country it is a foreign concept that was
that was brought about really in the
middle to late 20th century and it has
not helped our culture our culture has
not gotten better in most ways since
then so time to get rid of it
on this point of the ironic satanist
this is just a minor point before we
move on
i was reminded when i was reading about
these ironic satanists of this story
that didn't get a ton of play mike
cernovich
posted it around again recently too that
at cern
you know the large hadron collider this
probably the most important site for
physics research on earth
there was a film that leaked of a of a
satanic
performed human sacrifice like a sort of
a show ritual not a real human sacrifice
but a feigned
satanic ritual
at cern in front of a hindu deity
and you look you can watch the video
it's really it's it's real there's
people in these black robes
with fire all around and then a light on
i think it's a statue of shiva and then
a performed human sacrifice and she said
what
what the hell
is what are these scientists doing and
then cern made a statement about it
and they said oh
yeah the footage
was recorded as part of a prank
by scientists at europe's top physics
lab cern said that the ritual was just
it was just researchers and scientists
coming to work at the facility and
taking their sense of humor a little too
far hahaha yeah it's not a big it's just
a big funny ha ha it's just a funny
little hoax joke you know you know when
you joke you know you go out with
friends
and you maybe you throw a couple back
you have one too many coca-colas and
then you perform a black mass in front
of a hindu deity and you pretend to
sacrifice a human being ha you know and
then maybe when you shoot some pool
afterward
maybe you gamble a little bit too much
and you worship moloch and ball in the
devil you know how that happens ha
you jokester you owe you with your dry
sense of humor
i don't know about you that that
explanation doesn't suffice for me
i'm gonna need a little bit more
before i just write this off
this is you know gosh you got you've got
gay frogs
you've got weird stuff in the water that
the epa just admitted now you've got
devil worshipers at cern this is
this is really shaking a lot of
what what i had believed previously
about
how normal politics is
if if you do that if you engage in black
satanic rituals
ironically and
it's it's not ironic okay and it's bad
and it and the fact that this symbolism
uh continues to exist
is and has existed for millennia that
should tell you something if you're if
you're on the side with the guys in the
dark black robes and the fire performing
the human sacrifices you're on the wrong
side get on a different side okay
it's demonic stuff
that transgenderism is demonic it's the
only way to describe it it is a way i'm
not saying that the people who are under
the sway
of transgenderism and in the thrall of
this ideology are intentionally
worshiping demons but it is a demonic
influence that tells you that your soul
and your body are in opposition to one
another and you've got to mutilate
yourself it's just so anti-human it's
just so extremely destructive
and that
whatever whatever we know about the
devil we know
we know two things we know he's a liar
and we know that he hates life he
specifically hates human beings
and so when people are really anti-human
when they're really anti-life
and when they ground their ideas on
manifest lies
you gotta sense that the old the old
devil might be lurking around somewhere
and you probably want to get on the
other side
on this point of transgenderism
and demonic policy there is a new policy
from fina the international swimming
association that is
it's being reported in some some places
as being really good for the
conservative side and really
tough on the transgender side
because they're they're tightening up
the rules and they're saying
look these dudes can't just willy-nilly
compete against the women because
they're going to beat all the women and
so
they're they're going to have to uh
they're they're going to have to have
transitioned
before a certain age if they
transitioned before the age of 12 then
they can compete against the women
but if they transitioned after they
can't do that and then fina is going to
try to create an open category for these
sort of sexually confused people to
compete against one another that isn't
the male category
or isn't the the female category
this is a bad idea
they're trying to split the baby on this
and it's not going to work
first did you catch what the worst part
of this policy is
did you get it's the it's right there at
the top
if you transition before the age of 12
then
you can compete against the women what
does that do that creates an incentive
to transition to go on puberty blockers
and cross-sex hormones and chop up your
body before the age of 12.
what happens when you get when you
create incentives you get more of that
behavior so the result of this policy is
going to be an increase in the number of
poor little kids who get their bodies
all chopped chopped up and their lives
ruined so that their psycho parents can
get them to compete in the swimming race
where they think they're going to win
and get a scholarship
that's the first part of it
second part of it
this open category
just punts the question it says well
yeah we just don't want to rule on it
and so yeah men they're not men they are
men they're not women you
you can't you can't split the baby
on this okay you have to come to an
answer and the reason that people don't
want to come to an answer is because
they're squishes and because
they're cowards in some way and because
maybe they don't have moral clarity and
also because they don't realize how
common how much common sense ordinary
people have we are inundated with this
crazy transgender idea from every corner
and so we think that it's a common
popular belief it's not the vast
majority of people know this is
completely insane
you can say that you can have confidence
in fact if you say that you're going to
be more politically popular you're going
to win more elections you're going you
might be attacked by some of the
prevailing institutions but the people
are going to be on your side and they're
going to be on your side because it's
right either a man is
a man and not a woman or a man is not
necessarily a man and can be a woman
you've got to pick though
and if if it's the latter if you can
really be a woman born in a man's body
or vice versa
then then we need to trans the kids
and then that's fine and then we can
incentivize it below the age of 12 or
even younger because it's true right
then it actually would be cruel to let
the kids go through puberty
but if it's fake which we all know it is
if it's just completely absurd which we
all know it is
then you shouldn't do it at 12 or 14 or
20 or 75
it's wrong and destructive
we haven't lost this issue
there are some conservatives who want to
preemptively surrender this issue
because they're the surrender party
because they're the john cornyn party
because they're giving in on very
important issues not just gender talk
about gun rights talk about
constitutional rights without any need
to whatsoever but we haven't lost this
issue we haven't even lost marriage by
the way
we we just radically redefined marriage
in this country the supreme court did
within the last decade
changed the definition a marriage to
something that is completely
unrecognizable from all of human history
and then what happened the squishes
right away they said okay it's over move
on time to move on they're all the
squishes were thrilled when the supreme
court redefined marriage it's over gotta
move on it's not over guys it's not over
actually people are still
people are still standing up on this
issue because
because the truth is on our side
there's a court in japan
that just ruled
that the japanese constitution
does not prohibit bans on same-sex
marriage
there are there are this is such a
semantically complex sentence it's it's
hard to even make sense of it
because
for
because the marriage debate was never
about whether or not you should ban gay
marriage it was never about whether or
not you should legalize gay marriage it
was never about whether gay people
should have the right to get married the
marriage debate really was always about
what is marriage
wasn't about hating gay people and
wanting to go
to attack gay people and throw them off
a rooftop it was not about any antipathy
whatsoever it was about a very simple
question that had been simply answered
for all of human history until five
minutes ago the question was what is
marriage
and at the very most basic level i think
every society everywhere forever has
said that sexual difference the
difference between men and women
has something to do with marriage
the complementarity of the sexes the
idea that
you come together and have the
openness to the possibility of life
making a family and having kids that has
something to do with marriage
and it's not that they're
that everyone gets to have a kid it's
not that there aren't problems and
eccentricities in people's marriages but
but marriage looks like something
and then the supreme court in obergefell
anthony kennedy the romantic poet
decided nope doesn't look like that at
all doesn't mean anything it's whatever
i say it is
love is love equal sign equal sign equal
sign well this court in japan just said
no that's not true the osaka district
court
sided with the argument from the country
of japan
which said that quote the purpose of
marriage is reproduction and it agreed
with the definition that marriage is a
relationship between a man and a woman
to bear children and raise them together
in cohabitation
osaka said that the marriage system is a
system that exists based on the
pragmatic purpose of the society
protecting men and women to bear
children and raise them that's true why
do i bring this up why do i bring up
this court case from japan
just to remind you this isn't over the
surrender caucus the squishes don't need
to give this up
why have the squishes in the
conservative side gone weak on gay
marriage it's a simple reason and i
sympathize with it because they don't
want to be called phobes they don't and
they don't and they legitimately don't
want to offend their gay friends and
their gay relatives and they don't want
to be seen as haters and bigots there's
nothing there's nothing
hateful and bigoted about saying that
marriage has a meaning
and
people can
pursue pursue happiness as they see fit
and people can
have the intimate relationships as they
like
but
no one has the right
to
redefine reality
to something that it never was and is
not now and never will be
no one has the right it's not good for
anybody it's not right it's not good for
the gay guys it's not good for the
lesbian toys and toy story it's not good
for anybody else it
it doesn't
expand marriage and make it more
inclusive it just destroys marriage
because if marriage has any meaning at
all
it has to have something to do
with
sexual complementarity and at least the
possibility the logical possibility of
children
if it doesn't then then what is it
then what and why is it only two people
and why can't it be what's the
difference between a marriage and
a town or a state or a country it's just
relationships of people love is love
there are different kinds of course
speaking of
identity politics there's a coffee shop
looking to hire new people
and this coffee shop
puts in their sign to go hire people
they say
white
cis males
are the last choice
when you apply
if you're a black
trans female or maybe presumably you'll
be at the top of the list but if you're
a white cis male
you are the last choice and people know
this is wrong
but this policy already exists
we're all going after this random coffee
shop that libs of tick tock found
the policy already exists it's existed
for decades it's called affirmative
action
and you see it in college admissions and
you see it in hiring
the idea that
white people will be disadvantaged
because of their race
i'm not saying they're disadvantaged in
life i'm not saying oh woe is the white
people i don't know i got a suntan the
other day i'm not sure i count as a
white person anymore
swarthy people where do we fall on that
i don't know that's a topic for another
day
i'm not saying that there's no the black
people don't have certain
historical baggage in america i'm not
saying that
socioeconomically everyone's on the
level i'm not saying that i'm just
saying at a very practical level there's
a law right the only
the only legal racial discrimination
that you can have is against white
people and to some degree against asians
in favor of black people and mexican
people that's the law and so
yeah the coffee shop is being honest
about it people shot the coffee shops
being a little provocative and in your
face about it but that's
that's that's the rule for every other
business too just about
so if we have a problem with that if we
think that's unjust then we should deal
with that in our law and say no no more
racial preferences no more racial
discrimination that's wrong it's racist
we used to call that racist now we no we
don't call that racist
i think the majority of people are on
our side there i think the majority of
people get that the squishes don't
the
the
pudding heads who run our institutions
they don't get it
but the people do
frankly
even the heads of the liberal
institutions are starting to kind of get
it there was a report just came out of
of mediaite about cnn
says that cnn's president chris licht
the the new president who took over for
jeff zucker
just told cnn staffers
to stop referring to trump's election
claims that the election was rigged as
the big
lie the cnn staffers just like robots
had been referring to
to trump's questions about the election
as the big lie republicans are pushing
the big lie the big lie and they're
using that because it's a phrase that
was used by hitler and mein kampf but
these guys are so dumb that they don't
realize how hitler was using the phrase
hitler was using the phrase and accusing
the jews of perpetrating a big lie when
they were
uh when they themselves were criticizing
and going after a german general so with
what's ironic about the whole
saga is that cnn was putting itself in
the position of the nazis and
republicans in the position of the jews
but they don't know anything they've
never read a history book they don't
know what they're talking about the
reason that the new president of cnn is
calling for the the staffers to stop
using that phrase
is he he says it's worrisome or i'm
sorry the staffers are saying it's
worrisome that we're being told how to
talk about the worst things ever in
american democracy the president of cnn
is saying guys no one believes this
it's done it sounds dumb most people
know it's not true it's crushing our
ratings even these guys get it the wind
is at the backs of the republicans not
just the republicans the conservatives
not just the conservatives the cultural
conservatives now is not the time
to squish i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode
florida and the white house feud over
vaccinating young children explosive
testimony reveals new details about the
police response to the uvalde school
shooting and disney's new pixar film
light year disappoints at the box office
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire